the big news here in Britain melb
dropping more bombs shells and gettin
real about Victoria Beckham not joining
them on the Spice Girls - honestly she
said she doesn't want to go on tour and
so you have to be a respectful is that
annoying thing for the group it's
annoying to me well why not mmm but I
mean she has her reasons and she's got
her life well she's got her own Empire
fashion line of family and all that kind
of stuff that she's got on that in her
absence stop it
they'll be dist posh this morning on
Good Morning Britain and the singer
dropped a bombshell from her new memoir
brutally honest the great love of your
life you say was Eddie Murphy
yeah he always will be yeah I've never
really spoken about Bob it was love at
first sight you say when you met it yeah
could we caught it for quite some time
before you wish much stayed together
well you can't say wish I shoulda woulda
coulda it is what it is you can't no I'm
not gonna it was like a love story that
didn't have the perfect happy ending at
the end of the day we have a beautiful
daughter together angel who's 11 years
old and she's actually staying with him
right now whilst I'm here working
Eddie actually refused to accept he was
Angel's father until it was confirmed by
a DNA test Mel B also talked about
accusations that her ex-husband Stefan
Belafonte abused her but when a news
anchor read his denial live on the air
the singer became visibly annoyed mr.
Belafonte stole tips that there is new
litigation plans cause the Ottowa know
the allegation is against him in full
which he didn't do the right reply
should have a platform well when he
requires you can reply again no why
would I get into a spot like that yeah
it's my Porsche we have to do that one
of those we wanted to or not
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]